welcome to the man of recaps this is
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore jude law returns as a hot
younger dumbledore but the dark wizard
grindelwald is no longer albino johnny
depp it's normal looking mads mikkelsen
right off the bat dumbledore reveals his
first big secret he and grindelwald were
more than friends they were lovers of
course that's not a secret we've known
it for 15 years and although they're now
mortal enemies these ex-boyfriends can't
duke it out because they made a magic
blood promise never to fight each other
and so our adorably cute socially
awkward animal lover newt scamander gets
to continue to pretend to be the main
character there's a magic deer giving
birth but grindelwald's goon show up and
kill mama dear steal the baby but turns
out she gave birth to twins so he at
least rescues one of them now what does
grindelwald want with a baby magic deer
well they titled this franchise
fantastic beasts so they have to include
them but it's not cute and fun he kills
this thing cause now it's blood can show
him the future so now to fight a guy who
can see the future their plan is to have
no plan and act chaotically so if at any
point during the movie you have no idea
what's going on that's not bad writing
it's intentional so newt's commander
recruits his dream team first is the
muggle jacob kowalski only returning
member from the first movie remember his
girlfriend queenie joined grindelwald
last movie for inexplicable reasons and
doesn't do anything in this one except
stand around and look uncomfortable
while her sister tina newt's love
interest is not in this one at all she's
busy at work and jacob is not a wizard
so it's unclear how he's gonna
contribute newt gives him a fake wand so
he doesn't feel useless the rest of the
team are from crimes of grindelwald like
newt's brother theseus who we barely got
to know newt's assistant bunty who we
got to know even less and this totally
random dude who we know least of all
there's a new addition though the
hogwarts charms professor who's at least
memorable because she talks funny so the
team sets off to germany where there's a
big election for the international
minister of magic but the current
minister is secretly a supporter of
grindelwald's and pardons him for his
crimes so now grindelwald's running on
his conquer the muggles platform theseus
ends up captured so newt's gotta break
him out of prison which is guarded by
these tiny but terrifying nightmare
scorpions luckily animal expert newt's
commander knows how to handle them yes
he's gotta do a silly little dance that
makes them mimic it and it's actually a
fun scene of newt getting up to
fantastic beasts shenanigans meanwhile
jacob kowalski gets drunk and tries to
1v1 grindelwald with his totally useless
stick but new witch does discreet magic
so it's that thing where you give your
younger sibling an unplugged controller
and they think they're controlling the
video game meanwhile dumbledore is found
by credence who grindelwald just told
him is a dumbledore and now he hates
dumbledore for abandoning him and so
they have a big magic fight where cgi
everything's swirling around in the end
dumbledore wins and it's like look kids
are you grew up without a family but
it's not our fault you're my brother
aberforth's secret son he didn't know
about and speaking of secrets of
dumbledore we learn a new one their
sister who died young and it was maybe
dumbledore's fault he accidentally
killed her of course that was also not
really a secret it was pretty much
spelled out in the books but now back to
magic to your baby turns out it's a
chillin that can like read the goodness
inside people and grindelwald takes his
dead one into his magic jacuzzi to bring
it back to life under his control and
it's like look wizards let's throw out
democracy and let this baby deer choose
our leader and so our team has to get
the real chill into the election to
expose grindelwald's fake undead one and
to confuse grindelwald's future site
none of them know who has the real dear
so they're running around doing some
magic but they're too late the election
happens and of course the undead deer
chooses grindelwald but creighton steps
in to demand a recount yes he turns on
grindelwald exposes that it's a fake
undead baby deer and newt shows up with
the real one just in time okay who's
gonna really lead us it goes to
dumbledore but dumbledore's like yo man
i'm not running pick one of the other
candidates and so he does but now for
his betrayal grindelwald tries to kill
credence but his daddy abrafort steps in
to save him with his brother albus it's
a double dumbledore block spell but what
about the magic blood pact well for
reasons that aren't fully explained now
it breaks for some reason they're
transported to a pocket dimension and
it's finally time the dumbledore vs
grindelwald epic wizards duel although
it's actually not that epic they mostly
just stare intently and point cgi at
each other in the end they're evenly
matched and dumbledore doesn't want to
fight his former lover decides to leave
their real final battle for the next
movie that may or may not ever happen so
now grindelwald's under arrest but he's
peace and out of there you'll always
remember this is the day you almost
caught captain jack sparrow anyway the
day is saved for now credence gets to
hang out with his daddy aberforth
although apparently he's dying of
obscurus disease with tina out of the
franchise they hint at a new romance
between newt and his assistant bundy but
actually tina does show up for a quick
cameo at queenie and jacob's wedding
dumbledore apparently not invited he's
just creepily watching it from outside
and so with defeating grindelwald
unresolved and the future of this
franchise looking uncertain that's where
secrets of dumbledore comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]